des rugbys au cinéma il n'y a pas eu
vraiment surprise hier soir lors de la
36e cérémonie des césar les favoris ont
été récompensés romane polanski reçoit 4
statuette pour the ghost writer dont
celle de meilleur réalisateur
un bel hommage du cinéma savouré par le
cinéaste après ses démêlés judiciaires
et puis trois césars pour des hommes et
des dieux de xavier beauvois sacré
meilleur film yann fossurier avec 11
nominations il était le grand favori des
césars cette année des hommes et des
dieux de xavier beauvois reçu finalement
trois statuettes dont la plus convoitée
celle du meilleur film
tout d'un coup je me revois quand
j'étais quand j'avais 15 ans ou même
avant je n'ai jamais raté les césar et
quand j'étais petit j'avais envie d'être
dans votre famille j'avais envie d'être
copain avec vous je pensais pas aux
entraîné aux critiques gentiment des
hommes et des dieux raconte la tragédie
des moines de tibéhirine assassinés en
1996 en algérie
ce film événement a attiré plus de 3
millions de spectateurs dans les salles
hier soir il a également permis un
vétéran du cinéma français michael
lonsdale de décrocher son tout premier
césar à presque 80 ans celui du meilleur
second rôle masculin
voilà petit coquin
amis du temps là mieux vaut tard que
jamais l'autre grand vainqueur de la
soirée c'est romane polanski quatre
récompenses dont celle du meilleur
réalisateur pour the ghost writer un
film achevé en pleine tempête judiciaire
quand le cinéaste franco polonais était
emprisonné en suisse pour une affaire de
détournement de mineurs vieille de plus
de trente ans puisqu'elle ce film était
terminé en taule je voudrais remercier
tous ceux sans qui ce pourrait pas se
passer tout ceux qui m'ont soutenu parmi
les autres lauréats eric elmosnino est
élu meilleur acteur pour son
interprétation de serge gainsbourg dans
le film de joann sfar
sara forestier reçoit quant à elle le
césar de la meilleure actrice pour son
rôle dans le nom des gens
les mecs devrais-je scénique c'est moi
je suis toi mais tu veux que je te dise
unique je veux dire je n'y ferais le
bulletin sarkozy une récompense pour une
comédie loufoque c'est suffisamment rare
au palmarès des césar pour être souligné